um why don't we speak next to
let's speak to Rashad from is it Staten
Island
yep exactly what's going on
all right so David I um
I've been kind of thinking about this
recently I mean it's not very I guess
it's more of a shower thought that I had
okay but I actually think that
Biden would have well Bernie would have
done worse to Trump in the general
election and I you know that may or may
not be a hot tape you know but I don't
think Bernie would have won Georgia I
don't think Bernie would have won
Arizona
and I just think Biden has more appeal
with the because as much as people don't
as much as uh leftists online don't like
to realize it you know most Democrats
that actually vote not just tweet on
Twitter most Democrats actually both
prefer the more moderate candidate and
it's more interspersed throughout the
country
yeah I mean this is not you know whether
it's a hot take or not this this you
almost verbatim that was my analysis
during the Democratic primary and for me
it's less about you know some people
some people speculate and I think it's
idle speculation that Bernie would have
done better than Biden in the general
election my question has always been
what evidence do you have of that I've
not seen any the primary wasn't close
and especially when you think about some
of the states you're talking about
I I don't see how Bernie would have done
better than Biden
um if someone can explain it to me I'm
willing to have my mind change but I've
certainly seen no evidence of that
yeah it's just it just kind of bugs me
sometimes online yeah when I see you
know like leftists will blame like
everything from Bernie Lewis you can't
see the the um
we're saying that the shadow app go
great they blame everything else except
the pack the fact that people voted for
Biden over birming I mean yeah Bernie
won in California but you know
California wasn't exactly about to go
red anytime soon yeah no this is like my
my analysis of this is not based on what
I would like the truth to be it's just
the Democratic electorate is not well
represented by what you see on Reddit
and Twitter and we learned that in the
primary and I don't think there's
anything controversial about saying that
I think if we don't recognize it it
certainly won't change the first step is
accepting what the reality is
yeah I I totally agree with you well
thank you David my pleasure to call
great to hear from now I appreciate the
call uh thanks to everybody who called
in I'm out of time I'm unable to take
more calls today but there will be
Future Days on which phone calls are
taken and I look forward to speaking to
you then
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy.com Pacman I've been
using privacy for a little over a year
now you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even auto fill the card number
with one click and the payment is taken
out of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like I said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at privacy.com Pacman